week nine awards time mds joins us let's
do it like we always do we'll get right
to it best offensive player of the week
mds who do you have
i have devonta adams who had 10 catches
for 173 yards against the 49ers coulda
had more if the packers hadn't taken
their collective foot off the gas late
in that game
and you know he just couldn't be covered
and
when he is playing at the level he's
playing at and aaron rodgers is playing
at the level he's a
i don't know that there's a better team
in the nfc i i think they may be the
best team in the nfc they're a better
team than i thought they were going to
be this season and davonte adams may be
the second biggest reason for that after
aaron
[Music]
my choice and mike i'm stealing your
pick you had him last week i'm picking
him this week dalvin cook the vikings
running back had a career high 206 yards
two touchdowns he was fantastic in that
game and mike as you've talked about he
has put himself firmly in the mvp
conversation with the way he played he's
he leads the league now with 858 rushing
yards has a league best 12 rushing
touchdowns he is rolling and the vikings
are rolling because of dalvin cook
his last four games other than the one
where he suffered the injury early in
the third quarter with only 65 yards
rushing when he exited he's averaged 170
yards per game the last four if he could
keep that average up and that's a big if
he'll he'll obliterate the single season
rushing record so we'll see what dalvin
cook does but his odds for mvp have gone
from plus 8 000 to plus 4 000 and i
think by next week they'll be even lower
than that all right for me it's josh
allen he had an awesome day for the
buffalo bills one day after his
grandmother died she died unexpectedly
he was very emotional sean mcdermott the
coach of the bills gave him the option
to not play he chose to play he played
he played incredibly well he's back onto
the fringes of the mvp consideration and
the bills
knocked russell wilson out of the
driver's seat although he's still the
favorite he went from negative territory
to plus territory in the betting odds
but josh allen and the bills
reestablishing themselves i think they
got knocked loopy by the titans and then
by the chiefs and it took them a couple
of weeks to get their footing now their
footing is back and if they can build on
what they did sunday against the
seahawks off they go and they will be in
the conversation for one of the best
teams in the afc all right best
defensive player mds who do you have
i'm going to stick with the bills and
take aj klein the bill's linebacker who
had five tackles two sacks a forced
fumble
four quarterback hits he knocked down a
pass he he was all over the place and
you know i really like the way
the bills have built this roster and
it's moves like signing klein for three
years six million dollars a year not the
highest end contract for a linebacker
but a good solid contract for a good
solid player i think that's how you
build a winning roster not breaking the
bank for the top of the line free agents
i think the bills have done a great job
and aj klein is a big part of what
they're doing this year
i thought this was the hardest category
because there were tons of candidates we
could have picked and i went with the
pittsburgh steelers simply because on
friday mike we talked about
what we couldn't wait to see and i
couldn't wait to see which pittsburgh
steeler defender would be defensive
player of the week and i think it was
minka fitzpatrick he had an interception
in the end zone dallas was at the
pittsburgh five and if they had scored
there they would have been up 26 to 15
early in the fourth quarter and it might
have been over for the pittsburgh
steelers in trying to stay undefeated
but he made that play and then dallas
got down obviously for the last play and
mika fitzpatrick was there in coverage
uh on the very last play against cd lamb
and they gave him a pass break up for it
i don't think the pass ever had a chance
uh but he was there in coverage and and
never gave him a chance to to make that
play i thought he played terrific and
when he plays like that with the way
that defensive front plays pittsburgh is
definitely the best defensive football
i'm going to stay in that division and
go to baltimore chuck clark had a moment
for the ravens it was desperately needed
they were sluggish they were
sleepwalking they were still dealing
with i think the psychology of losing a
game that they should have won the prior
week and they just weren't making it
happen against the colts and you know
i'm home this year but i'm connected to
the nbc viewing room and chris sims was
saying man the ravens look awful today
they're not going to win the cults are
running all over them and then the ball
was out and chuck clark scooped it up
ran over philip rivers on the way to the
end zone and that was the spark that
reset the game turned it around and
opened the door for the colts to lose to
the ravens and for the ravens to get
that that loss to the steelers out of
their system all right best rookie for
week nine mds who do you have
well i probably took the obvious choice
but i have tua tagovailoa who
i didn't really like the dolphins
decision a week earlier to go to tua i
thought they should have stayed with
ryan fitzpatrick while he was playing
quite well and i didn't think tua played
that well in winning the first game he
played very well in winning their second
game against the cardinals i really
liked how in command he was of the
offense he could make plays with his
legs with his arm
i won't be surprised if tua takes the
dolphins to the playoffs and when they
first made that move i really thought it
was a decision that was basically
announcing they don't see themselves as
playoff contenders this year so i liked
everything i saw from tua enough that
i've kind of changed my outlook on this
whole dolphin season
mds i'm going with a player and a losing
cause but i think this is the game that
we were all waiting for jerry judy to
have he was terrific it was his first
100 yard game had seven catches 125
yards and a touchdown and really these
last two games i think we've started to
see who this guy is they've been his two
best games
back to back and he and drew locke have
found some timing and i think he's
caught up to maybe some of these other
rookie receivers and we're going to see
him have a great second half to this
season
i thought about going with jaguar's
rookie quarterback
jake lewton but he'll have to settle for
me
just not calling him luke jayton anymore
oh he's earned jake lewton and the
jaguars have earned some respect for
using sixth round picks on quarterbacks
who end up being halfway decent
between gardner minchi last year and
jake lewton this year but since they
didn't win sorry jake you don't get
rookie of the week shane lemieux the
interior offensive lineman for the new
york giants who was thrust into the
starting lineup last week and did very
well against the buccaneers brings in a
nastiness brings an edge that this
giant's offensive line needs and he's
going to be one of the cornerstones
to building the giants into something
better than they've been and when they
won the super bowl in 2011 and before
that in 2007 what do they have they had
a great defensive line they had a great
offensive line and it looks like lemieux
is going to work out they need him to
influence andrew thomas to maybe play
with a little more of a mean streak but
you need that that what jim mora the
younger used to call dirtbag mentality
you need a little bit of that at the
line of scrimmage when you're engaged in
hand-to-hand combat to impose your will
on the the opposing defense and lemieux
got that so he's my pick all right coach
of the week mds who do you have
this will be a little unconventional but
i have joe judge and i know the giants
are not exactly a great team
here with joe judge leading the way but
i'm starting to see some progress
and i like the way they are playing
they beat washington on sunday over the
last four
they're two and two and the losses were
by one point and two point i mean i mean
they're they're playing competitively
each week
and i think joe judge kind of has them
trending in the right direction
obviously the only way to make the
playoffs is if the nfc east proves to be
the worst division ever and that
happened but i like what joe judge has
his players playing like i think that
they need another year for the talent to
catch up but they look like they're
playing competitive football with joe
judge as their coach
mds i'm going unconventional too because
we sat here and said oh my gosh what are
the saints going to do against all these
buccaneers weapons well
defensive coordinator dennis allen the
aggie great had a plan and the plan was
great and he is tom brady's kryptonite
three interceptions three sacks they own
tom brady and dennis allen did a
fantastic job with that saints defense
i've got raheem morris now three in one
is the interim head coach of the atlanta
falcons the challenge is going to be
doing enough over the balance of the
season against some pretty tough
opponents the buccaneers twice the
saints twice the chiefs the raiders good
luck with all of that falcons but the
challenge for guys like rich mckay and
arthur blank
pierce through whatever the final score
is and ask yourself is raheem morris the
answer for this team going forward it's
entirely possible they just want a new
direction all together after the way the
past few years have gone
but
maybe their their best play is going to
be to keep raheem morris and if nothing
else give him an opportunity give him a
couple of years to see if he could be
the right guy because if you let him go
and he goes somewhere else and becomes a
great head coach you're going to wish
that you had kept him around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports